today's video is made different i threw
away all my fancy editing tools like
adobe premiere and after effects and
instead did all the editing with
javascript code thanks to a tool called
remotion which allows you to create
video content programmatically with
react when you think about it a video is
just a function of images over time
every second we might render 60 still
images or frames each one changing
slightly to create an animation react is
a great tool for describing uis that
change over time so why not use it to
describe video content as well that's
the idea behind remotion which opens the
door for web developers to storify their
data for example you might use a weather
api to fetch the local weather forecast
then use remotion to animate a video out
of that data if it's raining show some
raindrops if it's cloudy make some
clouds float by and if there's a tornado
show the entire town being destroyed by
the end of this tutorial you'll know how
to create your own custom data driven
videos from scratch using nothing but
javascript and remotion if you're new
here like and subscribe and check out
the full source code on github before we
jump into the code for this project i
want to give a huge shout out to william
candione he put together the code for
this video and has an awesome youtube
channel that you should definitely be
subscribed to and respect to johnny
burger the creator of remotion this
tutorial is unlike anything else out
there and by the end of it you'll be
able to add video editor to your resume
and you might be surprised at how easy
it really is to create videos with react
once you understand the fundamentals of
video animation if you go to github and
clone the project it'll pull up a
browser window that allows you to scrub
through the entire timeline of the intro
that you just watched and you can modify
it using html css and javascript what
i'm going to show you in this video is
how to recreate the weather scene from
scratch to follow along and create your
own video right now run npm init video
from the terminal to initialize remotion
it provides a variety of different
templates to start with my goal is to
show you the basic step by step so i'm
going to choose a blank typescript
template the first place we'll go is the
video.tsx file which contains a remotion
video component think of this component
as your entire video now a video is made
up of one or more compositions remotion
allows you to visualize these
compositions in the browser by running
npm start you'll notice in the full
project that we have a bunch of
different compositions here on the
sidebar these are like their own little
mini videos that allow you to isolate
and inspect each scene in the video now
back in the code you'll notice a
composition has a variety of different
props it has an id to identify it in the
video player but more importantly it
references a react component that
contains the actual ui that you want to
show before we get to that point though
we'll need to determine the resolution
for the video which i'm setting to 1080
by 1920 to give us a portrait and also
the duration the duration is the number
of frames that will be rendered for the
scene a frame is basically just a still
image at a given point in the video now
the actual length in seconds will be
based on the frames per second if we do
120 frames at 30 fps that will give us a
video length of 4 seconds now let's go
ahead and shift our attention over to
the composition file this is where we'll
define the actual graphics for our video
inside the component we have a div with
the text of hello world now we can style
it with css using inline styles here
using inline styles allows us to modify
them programmatically now if you open
the video player you should see a 4
second long scene that says hello world
that's pretty cool but also extremely
boring how do we make the video do
something cool remotion provides a
variety of different hooks to provide
data about the video with use video
config we can grab data about the fps
duration and resolution and we can use
that data to calculate values for our
animations or as i'm doing here display
it directly in the video content but
more importantly for animation the use
current frame hook will give us the
current frame in the timeline remember
this react component will be re-rendered
for each frame in the video we can use
the current frame to calculate a slight
difference between each frame to create
an animation here's an example of how
you might create a fade animation let's
define a variable for opacity as the
current frame divided by the total
duration in frames that'll give us an
opacity that starts at 0 and gradually
increases to 1 over the duration of the
video now we can use it as the opacity
value in the css and the end result is a
linear fade in animation when we preview
it in the browser pretty simple but
remotion has a bunch of other powerful
features baked into it what i want to do
next is integrate an svg graphic into
the composition i'm creating a new
component that will be a map of france
and in the jsx i'm simply pasting an svg
graphic that i found on the internet the
cool thing about svg is that we can use
and modify its source code directly
inside our javascript unlike a png or
jpeg file you can find the svg code on
github or experiment with one of your
own svg graphics now to make our lives
easier remotion provides a bunch of
different helper components and
functions one of which is absolute fill
this component will absolutely position
the child so you don't have to manually
configure all the css properties now i
am going to add some additional
alignment and padding to position it
right in the center and then we can
simply import this component into our
composition and declare it there that
graphic should now appear in the video
that's pretty cool but now let's take
things a step further and do some actual
svg animation you'll notice in the full
demo that a bunch of raindrops randomly
animate in from top to bottom this
effect is accomplished with a single
raindrop svg let's first create a new
component called raindrop inside of it
i'm adding an svg graphic of a single
raindrop to the jsx the svg will have a
variety of dynamic styles we can use
transform to give each raindrop a
slightly different size but more
importantly we'll animate the absolute
position of it like left and top to move
it from top to bottom but the real
question here is where do these values
come from some of them will come in from
the parent via props like the delay x
position and size we will randomize
these values in the next step the tricky
part is making a raindrop go from top to
bottom for that we'll need to
interpolate the top position that sounds
like it might require some fancy math
luckily remotion has our back here with
an interpolate helper function in our
case we provide it with the frame minus
the delay then an input range and output
range the output range is the actual top
position which will start off the screen
at 0.2 on the y-axis and then animate to
the bottom off the screen at 1.1 on the
y-axis that'll get the job done but we
can make our animation even more
realistic by making it kind of bouncy
and gooey because remotion also has a
primitive called spring to add spring
physics to your animations to use it
we'll create a variable called drop that
calls the spring function it takes the
frames per second as well as the frame
minus delay as arguments and you can
customize the springiness with damping
and stiffness using that as the
interpolate input will give us a more
interesting effect that takes care of
one raindrop now the question becomes
how do we randomly animate hundreds or
millions of raindrops at the same time
to handle that we'll create another
component called rain inside of it we'll
start by defining a variable called
drops that contains 300 true values in
it each value represents one raindrop
what we want to do is randomize the x
position delay and size of each raindrop
let's map each value in the array to an
object of those values and once again
remotion helps us out here by providing
a random helper that can generate random
values with a seed which means you'll
get the same random value given the same
seed that takes care of the
randomization now one extra step we'll
want to take here is to wrap this
function in use memo with react and pass
it an empty array as the dependency
because we only want to run this
function once when that component is
first initialized remember it will
re-render for every frame in the video
and we don't need to recalculate on
every frame now in the jsx we'll use the
absolute fill component and then map
over the raindrop array to display each
individual range drop and pass at the
required props and that's all it takes
to make it rain let's go ahead and take
the rain component and declare it in our
composition and then preview it in the
browser that should give you an end
result that looks something like this
that's pretty awesome but in the full
demo we have additional weather
animations like clouds and tornadoes and
they're rendered conditionally based on
actual weather data that comes from an
api that's pretty cool but now let's
render it to a real mp4 video that we
can upload to tiktok or youtube you'll
first need to have ffmpeg installed on
your system from there if you go into
the package.json file you'll notice a
build script it contains the input and
output files as well as the id of your
composition you'll want to make sure
that matches whatever composition id
you've chosen now go ahead and run npm
run build from the terminal and it will
render out your code to the out
directory as an np4 file congratulations
you just made a video with react what i
find so cool about this is that it
provides a really nice way to generate
videos programmatically based on some
kind of underlying data source my plan
is to connect it to gpthree along with
the giphy sdk to automatically write
produce and edit all my future youtube
videos i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there and give remotion a star
on github and let's see if we can get
them past 10k thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one